a deadly tropical storm made landfall
this morning along the Gulf Coast
tropical storm Cindy slammed into Texas
and Louisiana at least one death is
blamed on the storm tens of millions of
Americans are in Cindy's path today as
it moves inland the massive storm
stretching from Texas to Florida is
pushing north and east maximum sustained
winds are up to 40 miles an hour
heavy downpours could trigger
life-threatening flash floods several
inches of rain have already pounded the
south David Beck knows in Biloxi
Mississippi where nearly nine inches has
fallen so far David good morning Gail
good morning the flood water is
knee-deep where we are and it has
continued to rise overnight get this we
are 300 miles east of where this
tropical storm made landfall overnight
but The Weather Service told us don't
focus on the landfall because the worst
from this tropical storm will be to the
east and they were right where we're
standing they've got up to and over 11
inches of rain but guess what
150 miles to the east of here of the
Florida Panhandle they're also feeling
the effects of this storm the rain from
tropical storm Cindy continues to be
relentless across parts of the Gulf
Coast bringing with it rising flood
water in low-lying areas this deadly
storm has already dumped several inches
of rain causing flash flooding and storm
surge from Texas to Florida in Fort
Morgan Alabama a ten-year-old boy on
vacation with his family was killed when
he was struck by this giant log that was
lifted up by a large wave in Gulfport
Mississippi
white caps crashed ashore as people
waited for the biggest bands to roll
through several water spouts were
spotted off the coast of the Florida
Panhandle and in Southern Mississippi
storm fueled twisters are being blamed
for snapping trees in this Biloxi
neighborhood I thought was the end of
the world you know because I mean that
was so allowed in Fort Walton Beach
Florida another possible tornado tore up
a local ball field and brought down a
tree that destroyed this truck not
usually one for loss at words but but I
am now I just I can't get over this
ninety miles west in Mobile Alabama the
storm ripped a mighty oak tree from the
ground tearing a hole through the roof
of this home and smashing through an SUV
I'm thankful nobody got hurt you know
the stuff that damaged in the house is
just stuff you know it can be replaced
get a get a look at this video of waves
crashing along the Biloxi pier not far
from where we are a big threat from this
tropical storm has been a rough surf
again that's where the that's how that
ten-year-old boy died in Alabama people
have been warned
stay out of the water there are dangers
you aren't even able to see charlie the
good news is this storm has downgraded
the winds have weakened now 40 miles per
hour it could become a tropical
depression today as it starts to make
that eastward turn in the North East
Louisiana and up into Arkansas David
thanks